good morning believe nation today's
message is the good ideas stay with you
over to you Stephen King people will say
do you keep a notebook and the answer is
I think a writer's notebook is the best
way in the world to immortalize bad
ideas my idea about a good idea is one
that sticks around and sticks around and
sticks around it's like to me it's like
if you were to put bread crumbs in a
strainer and shake it which is what the
passage of time is for me it's like
shaking a strainer all this stuff that's
not very big and not very important just
kind of dissolves and falls out but the
good stuff stays you know the big pieces
stay I had the idea for under the dome
when I was teaching high school back in
1973 and it was just too big for me and
I was too young for it and I wrote about
25 26 pages and put it away
there's a scene at the beginning of this
book where this woodchuck gets cut in
half when this dome comes down over this
town I had written that part when I was
in in my early 20s and just sort of
recreated it from memory
when I when I wrote the book so the good
stuff stays so I'm the kind of person
who likes to write things down I'm the
I'm the kind of person who and when I
have an idea whether it's 2:00 in the
morning or you know 3:00 at night or
whatever it is when I have an idea I
want to write it down I feel like unless
I can get it out of my head and now I
tend to just send myself an email and
write it in Evernote until I get it out
of my head i I'm unsettled I feel like
I'm gonna forget the idea and it's
something that I've wrestled with this
message of you know maybe I'm just not
gonna write anything down and the best
ideas that I have will just continue to
come back and come back and come back
and those are the ones that I should run
with and if I look at how many times I
actually look over that Evernote file
it's pretty slim
and I feel like I kind of do it anyway
where the best ideas come back to me
over and over again and that's what I
run with but I haven't fully embraced it
maybe it's not a fear of losing a great
idea and every now and then when I look
through the notes something does come
back and I end up running with it and I
fear that I may have forgot it if I
didn't write it down and I could have
missed a big chunk of a big project I'm
working on but maybe that's an
irrational fear I don't know this is
something that I want to play with more
I do know that when I was taking about
my 1 were to believe that's been the
foundation for this channel and a lot of
the you know work that I do when I first
thought about it I felt like it was too
big I felt like it wasn't the right one
for me I felt like I felt like it was
hard to live up to and the more I slept
on it the more time went on the more you
know I experiment with it the more it
felt right and every passing day that
big idea just stuck with me more and
more and more until I embraced it fully
and it became the basis of this channel
and my website and all the work that I
do so I think there's something there I
feel like I don't do a good enough job
on it and I wonder if it might be worth
an experiment for a week to not write
anything down I just trusted the big
ideas will stay there that's an
interesting one I'm gonna think on that
I'm not gonna write it down I'm gonna
think on that you know what I'll see if
it sticks
see if I stick so I kind of come back
from Orlando that idea is still in my
head did not do it I like it so the
question today today is do you write
everything down or you trust that the
big ideas we'll just stick leaving the
comments below I'm gonna join in the
discussion thank you guys so much for
watching have an amazing day continue to
believe and I'll see again tomorrow
morning for another shot of espresso
give me go